una carrera siempre nació para salvar
80 personas como si fuera posible y sin ellas.
Caos mientras desempolvan los silos que se encuentran en
Estaban tratando de contenerlo, decimos lunas.
para pasar la noche en una habitación para pacientes en el
hospitales en manos del cus y en una sola sesión
de Nassiriya en el sur de los reyes sí
Informar un poco a la policía a los profesores suplentes.
explota o dentro de nuestra habitación
Yo era el grito que el fuego si
se propagan más rápidamente, están bien
excluir contener el fuego en
cuestión de horas
dando paso al salón dorado real
caos de tubos de presión del corpus en un
hangares están buscando esperanzas de ser
Spo identificado en escalas de invernadero.
tanto como el primer ministro
de Irak con una reunión
emergencia con alto funcionario
ordenando indro gastado y destino y
arresto tanto del personal del hospital
como del ifel y el porte de pensamientos
civil de la provincia a meyer consolano
Renunciamos a nuestra persona para reunir un
Frente al cerrojo en par express hacia el sur está
insatisfecho con lo ruinoso
salud infraestructural irak ipo la
corrupción efectivo posavasos políticos
estan cansados ​​y espero que esten molestos
mientras el multi hace ruido la primera vez
que un centro de san luis y fuegos y
en el campo en harley d'este años 80
personas paredes y no cuando se produce o
tres explosiones y nada hospitalario
Luego, la ketamina les dio a los pacientes estos comités.
y se mueve en banda